welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Spider-Man no way home is back
in theaters with a more fun stuff
version with several additional scenes
and expanded sequences that do make this
film very much worth going to see again
in the cinemas because all this new fun
stuff deepens the meaning of the film
with some much needed context for the
memory wipe spell and some intriguing
setups for how the three Peter Parkers
could team up again in the future so
seriously go say it I mean what else are
you gonna do on Labor Day weekend go go
to barbecues who gets invited to those
seriously do you know that any happening
or let's break down and analyze all the
new scenes that were added to this new
version of Spider-Man no way home and
why all this new stuff is so thin and
important after an opening Zoom call
recording A Sitch from Tom Holland
Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire
thanking the fans the film opens pretty
much the same way with Peter Parker
getting out it publicly but then shortly
after this a brief new expansion comes
during Cleary's interrogation his
questioning now includes some queries
about the Washington Monument from
Spider-Man homecoming and then we see
the file that clearly Slams on his desk
and we see it's a photo of Peter in the
black suit from Spider-Man far from home
and Cleary asks tell me everything you
know about the night monkey this version
of film includes a scene with Tom
Holland's brother Harry Holland is a
thief who Peter webs up this is before
Peter gets stained with the green paint
that he scrubs out later in Happy's
condo that was shown during the newsreel
footage in the theatrical cut but now we
actually see the full scene where Peter
strings up the thief and then a bunch of
adults debate whether or not he should
have done this one woman goes you can't
do this anymore you're a child another
guy goes hey show some respect he's not
a child he's 14 years old and then Peter
tries to correct them but isn't just
everyone talks over each other about
what kinds of decisions teenagers can
make the guy who defends Peter says
who's been the spouse but then the woman
speculates that Peter and the robber
might be in cahoots and then Peter goes
I don't know this guy which is ironic
because the actors are brothers and the
robber plays into it saying that they
have been in cahoots this whole time but
then another guy throws paint on Peter
shouting Mysterio forever really the
most sizable addition was a sequence in
Midtown High School Peters and gym class
and the kids and Coach Wilson make him
climb a wall as he does so Wilson claims
look at that sticky bastard go someone
calls him a freak then on the way out of
school Peter passes Flash's book signing
table girl pawns over him then we get a
long jokey sequence where Benny Brandt
interviews coach Wilson Mr Harrington Mr
Dell flash Ned and Peter coach Wilson
calls the conspiracy theory that Justin
Timberlake was ever in in sync Mr
Harrington talks about his ex-wife who
ghosted him during the blip making him
think she dusted remember that scene and
far from home he says that she's now
gotten sucked into conspiracy theories
on subreddits but he still misses her
Flash and his book claims to an invented
the name Spider-Man Mr Dell says that if
he had gotten a bitten by the spider
you'd have a sexier costume with flared
legs Ned and Betty floored awkwardly
since their breakup and then in the
Segway Betty mentions the Statue of
Liberty's makeover and shows Midtown
students models for alternate lady
Liberties decorated to look like
different Avengers one made to look like
black widow another for Hawkeye with his
bow and arrow one for Hulk one for Thor
holding a mjolnir instead of a torch
with a red cape and then she mentions a
PSA from Principal Marita remember him
this was Kenneth Choice character from
homecoming grandson to Jim Morita from
the first cap film this PSA is going to
be about cafeteria safety we'll see that
later then later in the film there's a
Quick Clip showing Peter Aunt May in the
Multiverse men all crammed together in
Happy's elevator and this leads to a new
scene where agent Cleary and dodc agents
interrogate happy Hogan as Charlie Cox
Matt Murdoch defends him Murdoch says
happy is quote a law abiding citizen and
he has nothing to hide but then Happy's
phone Buzz is showing that door camera
footage that we saw in the theatrical
cut of everyone entering the condo and
Matt then leans over to happy muttering
happy stops sweating and happy asks Matt
how do you do that because yeah how
would Matt see that although if you're
sweating as much as happy probably is in
that moment you don't need to see it now
interesting new footage here of the
three Peters there's this little moment
between Toby and Andrew on the
scaffolding of Statue of Liberty Andrew
says there are things I wish I could
have done differently and the Toby says
to have a second chance and then in the
moment when Andrew says he's always
wanted Brothers he now goes on to say we
should all hang out Toby says it is nice
but we should focus on the and then
Andrew jumps in yeah not getting killed
I'll just grab your number at the end of
the battle and Toby smiles and goes you
got it so we get this promise of a
future team up between these characters
now I doubt they'd be able to call each
other on their phones across the
Multiverse but on the animated side of
this MO verse characters like Miguel
O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 have invented
Multiverse communication technology that
could if there's a live-action version
of this allow Spider-Man to sync up
throughout the web of life and Destiny
after this movie came out I even went
into theories about how in the comics
the spider sense is really called
arachna frequency and it's a kind of
multiversal magic that sinks all Peter
Parker's and Spider-Man variants
together so really their Spider Sense is
a way that they could call each other
where would they see them together again
maybe in a future live-action
spider-verse plot that'd be fun or if
our man Kevin Pagan can pull this off
maybe all three of these brothers could
make cameos and Avengers Secret Wars
with Marvel heroes from past and present
from all kinds of different franchises
all together on the same battle world
and I feel like here this is a signal
from these actors at least that they'd
be game to be part of another billion
dollar movie can we talk about hair for
just a moment for some of us it's a
daily concern gets brushed wash styled
and playfully tussled by old friends and
sometimes it falls out which can really
get in the way of all that other fun
stuff I just mentioned I don't want my
old friends winding up with a handful of
hair so if you want to keep your hair
from falling out you should use
keep so you can get quality expert care
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or a pharmacy keeps offers generic
versions of the only two FDA approved
hair loss products out there but at half
the cost of your local pharmacy though
you never have to go to a doctor's
office keeps has a network of Expert
Medical advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair that you have keep says you
covered hair loss stops with peeps to
get 50 off your first order go to
keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's keps.com
new rockstars but definitely the most
emotional new moment comes up when Peter
and MJ say goodbye before Doctor Strange
completes the memory wipe spell when
Peter tells MJ that she's going to
forget who he is MJ now asks quote can
we both be forgotten together so in
context MJ is asking Peter if they can
both be strangers to the world but still
remember each other but if you think
about it she's also saying that she
doesn't want Peter to be alone as the
only stranger to the whole world and in
kind of a Juliet to her Romeo moment she
would rather be completely forgotten
than live on on in Bliss without him in
her life this is one of the most
heartbreaking and beautiful lines in the
MCU it definitely should have stayed in
the movie so glad we got to hear it here
now the movie ends with a new
post-credits scene to replace the teaser
for Dr Strange the Multiverse of Madness
that ended the December release now we
return to Betty Brandt's Midtown News
segment first we see principal Marita's
PSA showing a guy slipping in the
cafeteria with Kenneth choi's voiceovers
warning everyone to read the signs now I
actually spotted this black and white
short film showing on a TV in the
hallway in the theatrical cut if you
look closely and I spent oh I was trying
to figure out what this was from also if
you think about it slipping in the
cafeteria totally works as another call
back to the Sam Raimi era remember the
2002 film when MJ slips on that orange
juice and Peter catches her the first
moment these two look at each other eye
to eye then we move on Indian in Betty's
Corner her tribute to her graduating
senior class she says it seems like only
yesterday that we were beginning the
adventure that we call high school and
what an adventure it's been we learn new
things we traveled the world we fell in
love we almost died multiple times we
made friendships that will last forever
and some of has disappeared for five
years and then reappeared but the less
we talk about that the better what's
important is that we made it and as we
look out to an exciting and uncertain
future just remember the memories we've
made here and the ones that we will
cherish forever and yeah during this we
see memories from Spider-Man homecoming
and Far From Home including new moments
showing Betty and Jason dusting from the
snap mid broadcast and the returning
five years later in the middle of
another broadcast whoever that poor
anchor was is gone because Betty
reclaimed her job but yeah spitting that
this talks about memory because if you
look closely these photos and video
footage all exclude Peter Parker one
chosen from behind at the lockers but
you don't see his face and another shows
them in Venice with a pigeon flying
directly in front of Peter's face after
this movie came out I did talk about how
it is kind of a running thing in this
Trilogy that Peter misses out on most of
his high school experiences because he
always has to run off and be Spider-Man
therefore he is kind of a no-show in
their photos anyway and this would
logically justify why it would be easier
for so many people to forget him I think
we all would have appreciated this more
as a post-credits scene even more than
that Venom tease or the Multiverse
Madness trailer which dropped online
anyway a week later because it would
have given us more of an explanation to
how this memory wipe spell is plausible
in Peter's life let me know your
favorite new scene in this new version
of the film you can follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]